you
[Music]
pleasure plank University of Zurich so
lots of stuff and that's only a partial
list and she's she's kindly joining us
thank you thanks um and just a sort of
context this is my academic job talk but
feel free to kind of jump in with
questions and I also have some backup
slides if you want more detail I'm I'm
certain things that may not be in here
um so basically this talk is to begin
talking about why you know your
grandfather struggles to make strong
passwords why you often click ignore
when your device asks you the update and
why your friends might have called you
once or twice to tell you that they you
know accidentally sent money to a prince
in a foreign country and then realized
that it was a scam and in general users
have to make a variety of different
security decisions so they get
confronted with warning messages they
have to avoid phishing emails in their
inboxes and they have to make these
increasingly strong passwords and we as
people are not always very good at
making these decisions and so despite
the fact that security researchers have
made a lot of advances on security
problems and there are a lot of security
tools being released regularly people's
insecure decisions can still lead to a
lot of risk and so there was an issue
recently around the wanna cry ransomware
attack where basically this attack
spread across the internet because in
part people had failed to update their
devices so there was a patch released
that would have fixed the exploit used
by the attack and even months after that
patch was
earliest people had not updated devices
and this wasn't just end users it was
also enterprises as well like one of the
British health systems and so these
insecure decisions like not updating can
be very embarrassing for users when they
get hacked they're costly in terms of
time and they can also be quite costly
financially and so a researcher at CMU
estimates that phishing causes between
61 million and 3 billion dollars of
losses in the United States and so as
security researchers or practitioners
we're trying to keep people secure and a
simplified level in order to do that we
can either try to change the people to
make them better at being secure or we
can try to change our systems in order
to have those systems accommodate for
people's insecure behavior and I and
other people in the field of usable
security argue that in order to do
either of these things we first need to
understand why people are behaving in
securely in the first place
so if I have like my bicycle and I want
to try to change it so that it goes
faster I would need to have some manual
or blueprint for understanding how the
bicycle works in order to figure out
what I need to change and so similarly
we want to have some manual to
understand people's security decisions
and then find the right levers to
address to try to make things more
secure and I do this development of a
manual of understanding using what I
call behavioral security so I combine
behavioral economic kind of traditional
security measurement analyses and social
scientific or HCI approaches in order to
try to build behavioral security models
that can help us scientifically
understand this insecure behavior and
then change systems to help address it
and in my prior work I've built these
behavioral security models in different
security domains and the reason that I
like not to just focus on say
authentication is because we want to
look for systemic patterns across
security domains where we can try to
make
more generalizable changes so I've
looked at things like accountant and
device security so password reuse
software updating two-factor
authentication also spam and fake news
so how do people perceive or misperceive
the truth how do we design systems that
can keep them away from false or
malicious information and then I've also
looked at enterprise security so we have
people like software testers or
developers who also have to make
security relevant decisions and they're
human too so they're not always perfect
in their ability to do these things and
finally this five looked at some privacy
tangential topics like encryption and
data use so why don't people use
encrypted messaging or why don't they
use it properly but before I talk about
sort of what comes out of these models
it bears backing up to figure out
whether people security behavior is
really appropriate for scientific study
so there's this old quote that the user
is going to pick dancing pigs over
security every time and in fact there
was an Instagram plug-in this past
summer that had lots of videos of cute
dancing animals and if you use this
thing it actually stole your credentials
so this was kind of a literal set of
dancing pigs and so the question is is
this sort of the right model of user
security behavior or can we try to find
some better like models of best fit for
understanding why people do what they do
so in this talk I'll speak first about
some experiments trying to test some
different economic models of security
behavior and then I'll talk about how
structural inequities things like
differences in socioeconomic status or
internet skill can influence security
behavior and how modeling those
inequities and then trying to balance
them in systems can help people stay
more secure and make sure no one gets
left behind and finally I'll talk very
briefly about some epistemology so
basically when does one use these
different sets of methods and how valued
or excuse me how valid
social science type methods in a
security context so you start out with
the model of best fit and so we have
this this quote about the dancing pigs
and then in 2009 Cormac had this
theoretical analysis that perhaps people
are being rational when they ignore
security advice because the cost of
doing all of this security behavior
without way the benefits and the
argument wasn't that people are like
sitting around with papers and pencils
and computing what's rational but maybe
their behavior is fitting this model and
so inspired by this I wanted to see
whether we could test rationality models
or rational choice models and see
whether they fit I user behavior and in
order to do that we need to be able to
do some experimentation so a lot of
times in analysis of user security
behavior we do measurements so we look
at log data and we see how have people
interacted with the system we build a
model based on those logs and this is
quite useful because we have good
ecological validity but even with a/b
test there's a lot of factors that we
can't control when we do measurement and
so I saw an alternative people sometimes
use surveys they provide people with
like a scenario and they say how might
you behave if this were to happen but as
some work that I had at CCS shows while
security surveys are useful for many
things they not great for doing
controlled experiments people don't have
enough attention to necessarily pay
attention to small controlled variations
so we really want to be able to do
experimentation to see how people make
trade-offs in a security setting and in
order to do that experimentation
I built a behavioral economics style
observational system so basically I
wanted to generate something that looks
like log data but with a lot more
control and in this system participants
are going to create a simple bank
account and this account is going to
hold their compensation for doing the
study and I'm going to set that
compensation to something they're going
to reasonably care about like their
hourly wage or twice their hourly
and just like the real world this bank
account is going to have a risk of being
hacked but I'm going to make that risk
explicit I'm going to tell you how
likely it is that your study account is
going to be hacked and I want to see how
you trade-off that risk of being hacked
against an option to enable some
security that will protect you and so in
this particular system that I'll talk
about today you can choose to enable
two-factor authentication and two-factor
will reduce your risk of hacking again
explicitly and it also increases the
time it takes for you to complete the
study and one of the nice things about
this artificial setting is that I can
actually control within some window how
long it takes for the code to get to you
and whether it's the right code the
first time so that I can try to control
your cough yeah yeah yes we're getting
to that in one second actually yes so I
specifically used crowd workers who have
a for two reasons so one is they have a
low hourly wage but more importantly
they earn money in small time increments
and the reason that that's important is
that if I want to look at the cost from
two-factor authentication that has to be
a relevant cost to the crowd worker and
crowd workers are in money from doing
tasks in like 10 seconds or 20 seconds
which Maps very nicely to how long to
factor takes so exactly and they're very
cognizant of their time so they tend to
switch tasks very easily and they're
really well attuned to that additionally
their hourly wage is about five dollars
which makes it feasible for doing
experimentation but absolutely the the
experiment would not necessarily
generalize to people with $200 hourly
wages absolutely yeah ok so they give a
little bit more detail participants will
enter their crowd work ID and then
they'll create a password and then
get some information about the study
similar to what I just told you so
they'll be told this participants told
their beginning the study with five
dollars in their account and they have
to log in once a day otherwise they lose
all of the money
this isn't hacking this is to make sure
that if they do two-factor they'll have
sufficient costs from doing it I also
did variations where they had to log in
once a week the results were quite
similar and so about 60% of crowd
workers do this full-time so they're
online quite regularly and if they're
hacked they lose all of the money and
this person was told that studies
indicate that 20% of users will have
their accounts hacked over the course of
the study and I can do some experimental
variation here so I can vary that hour
the amount of money you're compensated
with between this hourly wage and ten
dollars which I ran some experiments
with and I can also test some
traditional economic effects like the
endowment effect so behavioral
economists have an offline behavior
shown that people care more about
something they already have than
something they're earning so someone
would care more about the five dollars
they start with than one dollar and then
earning one dollar more every day even
though it's the same five dollars at the
end and I can also of course vary the
hacking percentage and I didn't pick
these hacking percentages based on like
real-world statistics about account
hacking because a there's not that many
of them and B it's not clear how they
would map to my weird scenario but I
actually looked at numeracy research
which studies how people interpret
percentages to pick values that they
would be able to tell the difference
between once they proceed past the
screen they have the option to enable
two-factor authentication and I used SMS
based two-factor not because it's the
most secure but because it's the easiest
to control the time it takes for someone
to receive the code the other thing is
that M trackers could have had some like
privacy worries around giving the phone
number and but in a pilot study I asked
them like how often they got asked for
their phone number in tasks and almost
all of the M triggers said that they
like gave their phone number out
regularly so they didn't really seem to
care that much about giving
one more person the phone number and we
did tell them in the consent form that
we were storing it you know in an
encrypted place and we'd get rid of it
and so forth um so again with regular
people that might be different yeah yes
so in pre study we sampled a lot of
these workers and almost all of them had
used it somewhere before and knew even
if I didn't know what it why it was good
they knew what it was and what it would
entail yeah we did have an extra page
like explaining it and I used duo to
factors that I had their explanation in
case someone had a question you had 20%
risk of being hacked if you do this it
reduces your probability to 2% yes yes
yes yes yes yes yes math yes so in the
post survey so I did a post survey after
they did it to see if they roughly
understood that 70% of them did
understand like the math and then the
other 30% at least understood
directionality wise but it was helping
them yeah turkeys tend to be actually
like relatively well-educated which
helps for this math yeah okay so I can
also of course vary the hacking
percentage between 50% of our coin flip
and 90% the reason I didn't do a hundred
percent was that in a pilot we tried
that and the triggers didn't believe us
so all of a sudden they thought that we
were lying so these were the values we
stuck with those who chose to do to
factory get a traditional SMS based text
with a code and they have to enter that
every time they log in and they have to
log in regularly to complete the study
um so in the experience I'll talk about
today we did a kind of micro
longitudinal study where we observe
their behavior twice so the first time I
invited 150 of them to play one round of
this game
where they could earn up to $5 and they
did this for five days a hundred and
twenty five of them finished which means
they filled out the questionnaire that
tested the math skills and also had some
questions about their demographics
unbeknownst to them we then gave them a
five-day break and after the five-day
break we invited 125 who finished to
play again and they were told that we
were going to be honest with them again
but they were gonna be assigned to some
new condition and so they you know last
time had no impact on this time and a
hundred and seven people finished both
rounds of the study and we didn't do a
fully factorial design so we didn't try
every single combination but we covered
a range of effective risk if you combine
the hack and the protect percent as well
as variations in this endowment and earn
and in some experiments I won't talk
about with ten dollars as well
unsurprisingly only about half of the
people decided to do two-factor
authentication and if you look at some
industry adoption statistics this is in
the range of what you would typically
see and so this takes us back to the
question of whether or not people are
making rational trade-offs and with
their costs on their benefits so now
we're gonna do a little bit of math to
see whether their decisions follow this
this rationality so cost of two factor
is the amount of time they spent just on
the two-factor part of signing up and
just on the two-factor parts of their
logins times their estimated hourly wage
the expected value from two factors this
dollars savings from the reduction in
risk and its rationale if the expected
value is greater than the cost so very
briefly if I have a participant who has
a 20 percent chance of getting hacked
and they're protected they have a
two-factor that protects them half the
time
well imagine that it took them a minute
to sign up for two-factor and 180
seconds to do the two-factor parts of
the sign ins then if they have a 497
hourly wage it cost them 33 cents in
other MTurk tasks they weren't doing to
do this two-factor their expected value
from two-factor is
10% reduction in risk times the $5 they
say in turn which is 50 cents so this M
trekker was rational because they
expected values greater than that cost
what we've seen across all the turkeys
is that the first time they do the game
48 percent of them are strictly rational
and they get a bit better at being
rational once they've used the system
before and one of the reasons we think
that this is is that they are starting
to have a tighter boundary for
estimating how much their cost will be
how long it will take them to do this to
factor and in fact when we look at
modeling which of the turkeys were
better at being rational we see that
those who have more internet skill which
is measured with like a validated
sociology measure and those who tend to
do more other security behaviors were
more rational again I hypothesize this
has to do with the more experience you
have online the more you've done to
factor the better sense you have of how
much it will cost you and again turkeys
are kind of hyper aware of time more so
than other participants yes no they had
a totally new account yeah so I paid
them out after the first one yeah
strangely yes and we actually even had
people who like forgot to log in
regularly or who got hacked who came
back to finish the questionnaire which
was surprising to me I thought that only
the people who stood during money would
come back but some of the other ones did
yeah the other thing we saw was that
people who are assigned to a higher risk
condition were more likely to have
behaved rationally and that's not
because they all did two-factor and it
got more rational as there was more risk
what we actually see as they spent
longer on the page where they had to
decide initially whether to do to factor
and this maps to some traditional like
behavioral economics literature which
has shown that people who are in more
resource constrained settings like
poorer people or who are at more risk
behave more rationally
perhaps this resource constraint gives
them some more impetus to think harder
about things so anyway in our case those
who had higher risk spent longer trying
to make the decision so some of them
were rational but we didn't feel like
that fully explained why only half of
them were doing to factor and so the
question then is you know are these
users boundedly rational can we come up
with like a small set of biases that are
skewing their cost-benefit trade-off or
are they paying attention advancing pigs
or are they just like flipping coins in
order to decide whether or not to do
security so to test this bounded
rationality argument we're going to try
to predict whether or not someone enable
two-factor authentication and we can
predict this in the first round as a
function of account value so in this
case the endowment or earn condition
which behaves very similarly to the $5
$10 situation and as a factor of the
risks that we showed them how likely
your account was to be hacked how much
you got protection and we're also gonna
add some controls so the first one is
password strength I didn't tell them
that how strong their password was would
have any effect on their risk but they
might have perceived it to be related it
could also be that people who make
stronger passwords are more likely to do
two-factor we want to control for these
things and we measure this with an
existing password meter we also want to
control for Internet and like security
expertise or skill using some
pre-existing measures and we'll control
for demographics in the model of the
first-round behavior these controls were
not significant and in general we had
variations and password strength but
there's not enormous variations in
demographics or skills with triggers for
example all right so the first thing we
see is that we have a replication of the
endowment effect so in this online
security setting if we build a logistic
regression model to predict whether or
not you enable two-factor those who are
in the endowment condition where they
started with $5 instead of having $1 in
earning more where twice as likely to
enable two-factor authentication and
that's something we'd expect to see in
other offline scenarios so they seem to
care
more about protecting the money they
already have and this trade at the
bottom just shows the logistic
regression results yeah yes so they if
they don't log in so for both conditions
if they don't log in every day they
don't get paid they don't get any money
so you couldn't like have a dollar and
then not lug it until the last day and
still get the dollar you would be still
get $0 but certainly your risk in terms
of losses is different like on if you
get hacked on day three you lost three
dollars and you get zero dollars or at
the end versus if you get hacked on day
three in the endowment condition you
lost five dollars although in both cases
you're still gonna earn zero dollars or
stand to earn five dollars yeah
always five dollars yeah no no no five
dollars total yeah yes yes yes so the
reason for that is that the experiment
took the turkeys on average like across
five days I took them 20 minutes to do
it and on em trick they would have
earned like a dollar 50 for spending 20
minutes so five dollars was actually a
lot more than we'd get normally yeah
yeah yes at the end yep always at the
end yeah yes yes yeah no only at the
beginning yeah partially the test this
effect exactly yeah
no no we told them like oh we're
building a new bank system and we want
you to test it out and try using it yeah
exactly that said by the time they do
the second round they may have figured
out because there's this hacking
phenomena that it was about security but
we didn't tell them that yeah exactly
okay yes so the other thing we see is
that if you're placed in a condition
with more risk of being hacked you're
more likely to enable that's good that
seems reasonable also if we tell you
that two-factor is more protective
you're also more likely to enable so
both of these are reasonable directions
and we have some interaction effects
where if you're in the endowment
condition and we give you more
protection from two-factor you're even
more likely to enable but our ultimate
question was not necessarily just about
whether the factors are significant but
how well do they describe the behavior
we're observing and so what we see is
that this model that these factors
explains 16% of the variance in behavior
and a good psychology model would
explain around 30% or 40% so we're doing
okay but not nearly as well as we would
like to do if we're going to base things
on these behavioral models and so the
question is if we go to round 2 and we
add some additional data can we get
better at predicting their behavior so
we're going to add two things the first
is costs so we're going to use the time
it took them to log into and sign up for
the system as a proxy for their cost
from doing to factors so it turns out
that the time it takes you to use the
system generally is highly correlated
with how long it took you to do to
factor and this despite the fact that I
used like an existing enterprise usable
two-factor there's quite a range in how
long it was taking different
participants to log in with this system
and that was actually correlated to
their socioeconomic status and their
internet skill yes question
yeah yes
ya know so this was actually like the
tab focused time so as far as we can
tell they were not task-switching yeah
yes okay and then the other thing we're
going to add is their past behavior so
we know what they did in the first round
let's see if they're anchoring to what
they usually do and we have some control
of this in the the measure about
security skill but we want to see about
anchoring in this task and what we see
when we the controls also weren't
significant here at side from the
socioeconomics costs covariance so what
we've seen is that though if we just
include your risk and your account value
we have a model that explains 9 explains
9 percent of your variance so something
but not terrific once we add the cost
the difference in cost to log into the
system we're able to explain 26 percent
of the variance of the behavior so this
is pretty close to what you'll see in a
typical psychology model of like why
people pick products in a grocery store
once we add past behavior with these
other factors we're explaining 61% of
the variance so that's a pretty high
proportion of variance for a human it's
a very controlled system so we're not
necessarily saying that that will
generalize to an industry setting but it
shows us the strong influence of costs
and also past behavior what this doesn't
mean with the past behavior is that
people always did the same thing so if
we put them in a really in like a medium
risk setting the first time they make
their choice if we then put them in a
super low risk setting the next time
they will switch to not using two-factor
and vice versa but they have a strong
preference for sticking to their typical
behavior and so when you're designing a
system this then raises some questions
about given some users with some set of
priors in terms of what they want to do
how do I approach nudging them out of it
and how do I think about a person who's
never used two-factor before versus
someone who's been asked to do it a lot
and never has or who usually does it and
similarly with costs we then need to
think about whether certain users
maybe should get you bikies or some
extra help so that they're not sort of
unfairly investing a lot more for the
same security returned yes yes so in
this case yes because we have a
relatively small number of features and
the effects therefore have strong power
if we had more people than we might see
some effects from those controls for
example but I think they were too weak
for for that's I say okay well um so
this experiment is somewhat of an
example of how behavioral security can
help us go beyond sort of traditional
factors we think about which is will
this behavior increase your security is
there a risk to the user account those
things don't necessarily explain
terribly well why people are choosing to
do behaviors but once you factor in the
person's own abilities their capacity
for cost how much they value their
account and how they typically behave we
get a lot closer to explaining their
behavior and in future work I'll mention
briefly how we can try to build in these
kind of models to optimization problems
where we're trying to allocate a
security budget and see which users
should get which security requirements
or extra help so one of the things we
saw here right was this difference
between users in terms of their costs
for doing two-factor and it turns out
that that kind of inequity between users
is true not just in two-factor within a
lot of these different domains and these
inequities are based not just on skills
but they're also related to
socioeconomic status and at times to
culture so things like whether I'm a
user in a highly internet penetrated
country whether or not my country or my
culture is very collectivistic so I may
have different threat models in terms of
who's attacking my account and that can
change how well security protections
work for me or how I reason about
whether or not I would want to do some
behavior and so I'd like to give one
case study of how these inequities
can pop up in spam susceptibility and
then how we think about trying to
balance them out in a system so there's
a lot of prior work on email spam why do
people fall for email spam a little bit
of work on Twitter spam relatively
little work on why people fall for spam
on Facebook so that's what I will talk
about here this project was a
collaboration with Facebook and is a
more traditional kind of security
measurement so using log data to look at
why people are falling for spam and I
had two research questions I was
particularly interested in looking at
spam susceptibility so the first was
that work on email spam has proposed
some inequities in terms of gender age
and also skill as far as who falls for
spam and their email but these factors
hadn't been quantified very much and
also hadn't been quantified in context
of other factors that are more
traditional for spam like who's sending
the content and so on and so forth the
second thing is that social spam allows
us to look a little bit more at social
influence and so on Facebook outside of
the u.s. in particular people's networks
of whose sharing content are typically
very country centric so mostly it's
other people in your country who are
part of your network and so as a first
kind of looking at this sort of network
influence and I wanted to see whether
having other people in the country who
are sharing spam or clicking on it or so
forth had any influence on whether you
yourself were going to do this and this
was driven in part by prior works that
had shown that if you tell people like
ten other people have done two-factor
authentication they're more likely to do
it - that's encouraging a good behavior
can we also encourage bad behaviors in
the same way so in order to answer those
questions we're going to analyze about
six hundred thousand records of User
Content interactions so half of these
are interactions with spam so there are
viewer content pairs so I have some
viewer some piece of content that is
known to be spam and whether or not that
viewer clicked on that spam and these
are sampled over the majority of a month
because those different pattern
and the spam by day of week and so forth
yes so Facebook spam is anything that
tries to gain a legitimate financial
game so phishing distributes malware
hijacks accounts the most interesting
one is this last one which is it fails
to deliver on a promise outcome so what
that means is if you see a preview in
your newsfeed for an article about kale
and you click on it and you get an ad
farm that fails to deliver on a promise
outcome however if you click on it and
you get three sentences about kale and a
bunch of ads that does not fail to
deliver on a promise outcome so they
have a very narrow definition of failing
to limit yes so the way the Facebook
detects them and is they have
classifiers detecting as the spammers
write the spam so most of it gets caught
then and then some of that makes it onto
the news feed they have more classifiers
running they also have humans like users
reporting things and then they flag
something as spam in this data set we
have everything that was flagged as spam
and then we had human labelers rego over
it to make sure it was actually yeah and
then the other half of the data set oh
and and specifically we looked only at
spam that contained the URL you also
have spam on Facebook trying to get
people to call phone numbers but I have
no way to know if they did that the
other half of the data set is what I
would call him so this is explicitly non
spam and the reason for that is if I
just model why people click on spam and
no way of knowing that it's why they
click on spam and not why they click on
Facebook stuff so I want to be able to
compare why you click on Facebook stuff
with why you click on spam in particular
all right so we're going to have some
sets of features to try to investigate
these problems of inequity so we'll have
demographics of age and gender we also
have a proxy for skill which is your
activity level on Facebook which is
measured as the number of days over the
last twenty eight you were active and
the reason it doesn't have to do with
time spent or what you were doing is
because different countries have super
different norms about what people do on
Facebook and this is kind of the most
general metric for activity that they
have been able to
and we're also going to have some
country attributes so how prevalent is
spam in your country as well as clicking
norms so what's the ratio of clicking on
spam to clicking on ham or regular
content and it turns out that in some
countries that ratio is greater than one
because for various cultural reasons
people click on spam very often or click
on add farms for various different
reasons and finally we're going to have
more traditional spam factors like your
relationship to the content and whether
the content was Reshard and I won't talk
about those today but wanted to put them
up here because they're in the model and
all right so we're gonna feed these
features into our classifier and we're
going to predict whether or not you
clicked on some content we're gonna
build one classifier for spam and one
for him so that we can compare the
features and we find that the area under
the curve for spam is 0.72 and for ham
is 0.8 and both of these metrics are
significantly higher than the same
metrics for the classifiers would
actually run to identify the spam on
Facebook and so we went ahead with these
and because the logistic regression
gives us nice explained ability and we
also tried this with like more fancy
classifiers and were able to improve the
accuracy for when they actually want to
predict like high-risk users okay so one
of the first things we found is that
women are more likely to click on spam
and this had been mentioned in Prior
email spam work as well but we saw a
quantified effect which was that women
were 19% more likely to click on spam we
thought that was maybe more interesting
than some of the other research
questions to try to figure out why that
was and so in order to figure out why
that was we first took a look at what
kinds of spam people were seeing so what
we did was we took her yeah yeah yeah
yes they are yeah um not true of older
people older people are more likely to
click on anything but no difference with
spam yes yes so we took a random sample
of 250 pieces of spam and created a
codebook of the types of spam
we were seeing and then we took another
random sample coded independently the
spam into those code books and then
estimated the prevalence of these types
of spam in our sample and what we see is
that we have essentially three types of
spam the first is shopping spam so
something trying to get you to buy any
kind of product the second is media spam
so that's videos and most of those are
adult content or graphic content videos
and finally we have Interactive's which
are like games and it turns out that if
we look at the click-through rate for
anyone across anyone for shopping and
media spam shopping spam is twice as
effective as media spam and even when we
actually pulled in these samples we had
initially thought we ran the query wrong
because it's pretty clear that like
adult videos and graphic videos like the
headings are not supposed to be on
Facebook on the other hand the shopping
spam looks really similar to regular ads
and so we thought that maybe we got ads
in our data set the spammers are just
very good at the shopping spam and so it
turns out that women see the vast
majority of the shopping spam and then
see the vast majority of the media spam
and we also checked differences in
internet scale between men and women and
we didn't find any significant
difference and that's true in other
literature on differences in skill on
Facebook and so it looks like is that
women actually are being given a harder
job of detecting this more effective
spam than men are and that's due to a
bunch of factors and the news feed
algorithm that thinks they'll be more
interested in this kind of spam and
therefore feed said to them and on the
other hand it's pretty easy to tell if
you've been on Facebook for a little
while
what kind of videos should and shouldn't
be there all right
the other thing that we found
interesting with some country effects so
people who are in countries with a high
prevalence of spam we're less likely to
click on spam then we hypothesize that
this had there we go this is further
support that having experience with the
Facebook system and what kind of content
should be there is important and
actually when we look at activity level
on Facebook that's also significant so
the more you're on Facebook the better
the content that's supposed to be there
the less you're clicking on spam and
this is true not just for end-users in
some work I've done with software
testers we see that they're better at
detecting vulnerabilities when they have
more experience with the system and it's
actually a significant leg up they have
on say white hats who are coming in from
the outside so system experience may be
a special type of security skill on the
other hand if you're in a country with a
high proportion of clicking on spam
you're more likely to click so as an
example if I have five users in this
study who are from Iceland they were
attending to follow the clicking norms
of the other 300,000 people from Iceland
which is fairly interesting and not
something we necessarily expected and
with spam we hypothesize that this may
be cut me because social norms are
providing a feedback loop on insecure
behavior so in the US where there's a
very low ratio of spam clicking if I
click on spam or reshare it it's quite
likely that someone's gonna kind of
embarrass me about it or tell me that I
should take this down or report it or
whatever in a country where that's not
true people may even like the content
click on it give me a sort of positive
feedback for having done this and so I
have the opposite type of feedback loop
that's now encouraging an insecure
behavior and this fed into one of our
first system change suggestions which
was that in a targeted way in particular
regions or networks where there is a lot
of clicking on spam we may want to
surface the number of friends who've
reported a piece of content as sort of a
negative counter piece as opposed to
just the number who've liked a piece of
content or clicked on it and you've seen
Facebook doing this a little bit more
recently with fake news the other thing
is that we have this issue around the
shopping spam right and one of the
problems is that the shopping spam looks
a lot like real Facebook ads so we could
try to put authenticity indicators on
the ads and but one of the problems with
that is families could just try to spoof
these authenticity indicators right and
so the other thing that we wanted to try
to do was to use NLP or like very basic
other kinds of mission
in order to identify things that were
promotions that hadn't gone through an
official ads pipeline so if this thing
looks like a promotion but it didn't go
through an official pipeline then it
should be flagged for a review or at
least down ranked to get it further out
of people's newsfeeds
know so that the shopping spam usually
actually steals credentials you never
get the product it's not really selling
anything it's sort of like the viagra
emails yeah yes so if you sometimes they
will send it to you yes many of them I
think yeah from stategies their work
they almost always sent it then although
I want to say I saw an updated paper way
yes this often now they're having like
the the Ray Ban ones that you'll
sometimes get the product will never
show up or once they actually click on
the link it will take them to like a
drive-by malware downloads yeah yes
because you can actually so one of the
the special issues for women is that
they have a lot of multi-level marketers
in their news feeds and that's actually
allowed on Facebook you can do not add
promotion of those things and that's not
considered spam and then the final thing
is we can make some changes to
classification so at the time that that
this project was done Facebook was not
using click-through rates as a feature
or as any kind of feedback in spam
classification so they were very focused
on getting spam out of the newsfeed like
away from eyeballs but arguably spam
that you see that you don't click on is
a lot less dangerous than spam that you
click on and so the suggestion is to
start prioritizing advances in
classification for this high
click-through rate spam and keeping
track of new high click-through rate
content that's popping up the second
thing is that we may need to start
having separate classifiers or
classifiers that take into account the
type of spam as opposed to just looking
for black hole links and
sort of less nuance spam factors so I
worked with Facebook on implementing
multiple of these changes but they don't
let me tell you which ones or what
happened after I am fomented them with
them
all right and so I talked about these
economic and then measurement approaches
the last approach that they typically
use is more social scientific and the
social scientific approaches are helpful
for looking at more broad questions so
outside of say just two-factor or just
Facebook spam and during my PhD I
received a grant of survey data that
I've used to do a lot of this analysis
and this survey data asked questions
about general security and privacy
behaviors and experiences and it was
conducted using a probabilistic random
digit dial which is the gold standard
for doing surveys aside from doing a
census sample and basically what this
methodology allows you to do is the
company will take a mailing list of
different all the people in the United
States it will link those to landline
and mobile phone numbers it'll look at
which types of people are under covered
it'll actually go visit them and give
them a telephone and phone access so
that they can be sampled and then
they'll do their random sampled survey
and this allows them to have nearly a
nonzero chance of talking to anyone in
your given sample you care about like
the United States and then once you see
the proportions of types of people who
have responded you can compute a
confidence interval for how well the
responses should represent the whole
population so essentially this
particular dataset that I received was
weighted to generalize within 2.7
percent of the opinions of people in the
United States with a bit of variation
and confidence neural Bowl by specific
subjects and I use this to look at a
bunch of different inequities in terms
of where people get advice about
security numbers of incidents
experienced and so forth but the one I
want to talk about very briefly is that
inequities may be able to be in here
so in this survey we asked people about
their privacy behaviors so things like
whether they block cookies whether they
use private browsing so on and so forth
and for those who are parents we ask
them how important they believed privacy
was for their children
and then we ask them a battery of
questions about whether they help their
children with various types of privacy
things so like did you help them set
their privacy settings did you talk to
them about posting online did you talk
to them about cookies so on and so forth
and what we see when we look at to
parents who have the same behaviors and
who put the same amount of importance on
privacy is that the parent who has a
higher income between two different
households is 66 for 66% more likely to
have reported helping their child with a
variety of privacy behaviors so if we
look at this in a chart we have the
proportion of the u.s. population on Y
and income buckets on X and the light
blue are the ones who reported that they
helped their child with a variety of
these behaviors and as income goes up
the proportion who have reported helping
their children also goes up and so this
is quite concerning because we're
typically assuming that young children
are sort of digital natives and they're
coming into adulthood with all of these
digital skills but if some of the
children are getting different digital
skills at home than others we have some
policy questions around doing privacy
education in schools and where that
education is supposed to fall and this
difference becomes more pronounced if we
look at education so parents who have at
least some college education are three
times as likely to help their children
as other parents and there's a number of
like structural factors like working
multiple jobs and various other things
that can factor into this all right um
so we used a variety of different
methods which Lee raises the last
question which is when do you use which
of these methods and the answer is
certainly not when Facebook decides to
collaborate or when you get a grant of
data right we want to be a bit more a
bit more scientific than that and so
recently I've done some work comparing
when you
want to use say log data versus survey
data to answer different questions so
specifically I had host records of how
people had responded to update prompts
so being prompted by various
applications to do a software update I
can try to model from that log data why
you chose to update which application
did it mention security in the update
message had you had negative experiences
etc etc hey or I could do a survey where
I present those messages to you and I
asked very similar questions and
generate a model and so this paper looks
at when which approach is more or less
relevant and where what kinds of
research questions are valid to answer
secondly we have different kinds of
samples we can use so the first study I
mentioned I used Amazon Mechanical Turk
a lot of researchers also use web panels
which are sort of convenient samples of
users that have demographics that match
those of the US for example but aren't
sampled in this very intensive
probabilistic way and so we want to know
how well do the results from these
samples match those that come from these
probabilistic approaches and that's
something I'll be presenting at Auckland
in a couple of months and finally for
the the first behavioral economics thing
that I mentioned I'll be releasing this
eventually as an open source platform
where other researchers are able to do
different kinds of experiments also
beyond two-factor authentication but
with things like updating pretend games
that are in the system as well all right
so future work what's next the first
thing is doing more behavioral security
systems so a lot of my work thus far was
building models to understand what was
going on and making some point changes
to systems like the Facebook spam system
but the question is whether we can make
these models into more kind of
theoretical approaches to trying to fix
things and so the first approach in that
direction is to use mechanism designs of
some game theoretic techniques to model
the different kinds of levers where the
company has in order to increase
security which in
some things like two-factor and user
controls and see whether feeding in a
behavioral model of how this user actor
will behave can help us do some
optimization in terms of when should I
prompt which users so maybe I have a
user who just made a new account
I'm usually prompting them then and
there to do two-factor but they might
not value the account yet so maybe I
should sustain that risk for six months
and then prompt them once they have
gained some accountant value I can also
think about distributing resources so
perhaps giving a you Becky or some other
kind of resource to my users who have
really high costs or really high risks
in order to increase the likelihood that
they will go ahead and enable security
and in order to maximize my own profit
the second thing is that we talked a bit
about security skills and one of the
things that happens now is that if I
have users who are new to coming online
they're dumped into a very evolved
security ecosystem so most of us kind of
lived through various different password
policies that kept iterating that's not
true if I just go online now or I'm a
little kid and so we want to think about
how we can effectively teach people
those minimum sets of skills and one
techniques that may be able to be used
is is machine teaching and machine
teaching has been used for things like
how do I teach someone long division by
giving them a properly ordered and
minimal set of flashcards and so the
question is could we give our algorithm
a goal state of this strong password and
have it learn an inverse function of
examples but it would have had to see in
order to learn to create this strong
password and if it can learn these sets
of examples
can we see whether using those as sort
of intermediary steps for a user can
help them gain at some set of security
skills the next thing is to go beyond
security so in some work that I have
done recently when we asked people to
report to us over time experiences of
threat
or safety they've had online they talk
about some things that fall into a
classical security bucket some that fall
into privacy some other it's sort of on
the boundary and some things that are
more related to offline criminology and
so if I have had someone who threatened
me in person and all of a sudden they
pop up in my Twitter feed or they friend
request me that's now an online problem
as well not just an offline problem and
so recently while I've been in
Switzerland I've been doing work with
sex workers to understand their security
and privacy experiences and the
intersection of their behaviors with
offline threats of violence and stalking
and so forth and these kinds of
questions are relevant also to gig
workers so there is an increasing number
of women using apps to find domestic
work jobs and then there are certain
issues that can come from going into a
household and maybe not having enough
heuristics to determine if it's safe and
this is now a computer mediated issue as
well finally I'm interested in trying to
help practitioners be able to make more
rational decisions and practitioners
have sort of a hard job because we often
don't really measure for them what the
harms are from people having these sorts
of attacks or what their preferences are
in terms of what will happen to them and
so we're asking practitioners and users
to make trade-offs under a lot of
uncertainty right like you rarely get
the information that the account has
some X percent chance of getting hacked
and so in this work I'm thinking of a
number of different ways specifically to
quantify some of the impact of over
personalization and so one small project
which would be a collaboration with
Facebook eventually is to look at how
personalization of job ads affects
income over time so basically Facebook
and other companies have platforms that
Facebook specifically is building a
platform for blue collar workers where
they want to have them apply for jobs
through the platform and they'll
advertise jobs to them and the question
is if you're an electrician
and I so personalize your ads that you
only get ads for electrician jobs versus
I give you ads for electrician master
electrician and some educational
programs or I add some noise and you're
suddenly getting culinary ads and
plumbing ads how does that impact both
your own perception of your opportunity
space as well as your income or where
you apply overtime can I can am I
constraining you by over personalizing
and if I am can I show that there's some
harm there and there's other ways we can
look at this including looking at you
know if we add a lot of noise to the ads
or we confuse the profile that an
advertiser has about you how does that
affect how good the ads are that they
give you in terms of your own approval
and in terms of how well they value you
as a user the second thing is that we
can use people's preferences or try to
model people's preferences around
revealing information about themselves
to learn more efficient boundaries for
doing things like differential privacy
so for example is there some noise
threshold at which people are willing to
share certain types of information but
at which they're not willing to share
others and can we use some traditional
kind of behavioral economics information
revealing games to figure out where
those boundaries are so in summary I
blend multiple methodologies to try to
model why people don't behave securely
and especially to look at marginalized
groups people who have low socioeconomic
status or other types of factories that
couldn't create inequities identified
some of the early evidence of security
inequities which have led to policy
discussions around security education
not just for children also for adults as
well as discussions around kind of the
boundaries and defining what it means to
do work on security finally I've worked
on changes for not just Pham systems but
also suspicious login and two-factor
authentication design mostly at Facebook
but also some at Dropbox and finally
I've used these modeling approaches of
human preference beyond
and also in contexts like machine
learning fairness where we may want to
model a user's perception of the
fairness of features and then constrain
our search for an accurate classifier
based on meeting some constraints of
perceived feature fairness thank you
happy to take questions so they actually
did implement things and anecdotally
because I'm not able to take concretely
some of them did reduce click-through
rates on spam and so they were effective
one of the ones that I'm hoping to be
able to actually report on is some work
on suspicious login notifications so I
did some work looking at how people
interpret those notifications and one of
the problems is that on the back end we
have some prediction that this is a
suspicious login and notifications get
popped up at a range of classifier
confidence levels so if I'm someone who
gets a ton of these messages when the
confidence is 60% and it's usually
because I'm the PNA I have no way of
knowing that I just got a notification
for something at 90% and so I just
ignore that that's sort of a false
positive even though it isn't
necessarily so that's something that
they are not changing the UI design for
and may be willing to actually openly
report on the yeah
yeah okay yeah yeah yeah that would be a
fun study yeah so absolutely elimination
of that word because I don't know what's
actually happening on the kids side both
in terms of I they listening but also in
terms of for the kind of less resource
children are they getting this advice
from like somewhere else that wasn't
measured in the study the other thing to
your point is actually one thing I've
studied is whether people with like
security backgrounds or CS degrees are
any better at this stuff and the answer
is most definitely no so that's also
something that kind of always comes up
is just because you're an expert does
not mean you're more protected whether
or not you should be we could we could
debate it yeah a confidence is
definitely yes exactly you know exactly
enough to be very dangerous yes
precisely
if you make yes yes yeah yes yeah yes
yes the two things they're definitely
message lengths like when modeling
updating response we see a big effect
from that and I would I would lump that
in in some ways with costs right so like
my literacy level will have some impact
on that but also just like what else I'm
doing and how long it literally takes me
to read the text is an increase in cost
in terms of the requirements thing yes
so in the the paper about two-factor we
had this very hand wavy market analysis
about like okay so why don't we just
require the two-factor and then it's all
going to be good
and what we did and I caveat but this is
like theoretically hand wavy but
basically if we have some users with
some frequency of login they have some
values to their accounts if you required
2fa presumably given some read of
hacking you would have some pretty
significant losses in terms of user time
because they're doing a bunch of
security they don't need to do granted
in like a regular system that's not
MTurk you may not care so much about
user time but you care about engagement
loss and so that's definitely something
that i've seen and actually and when I
went to Facebook one of the things that
we discussed was even what they do is
they don't put two factor in even the
top three suggestions because of
reduction in numbers of logins so
reduction and engagement as well as the
costs of sending those SMS two-factor
messages which I accounted for in this
sort of handily the analysis and so
usually we would sort of not advocate
for the requirement both because it's
costly to you right in terms of
engagement but also because you can end
up on a rough line of like paternalism
in terms of
you know does the user have a right to
choose how much they value the account
that you are protecting and so banks are
now starting to require two-factor I
think in part under the a under the
assumption that you're going to value
that account but B if the policy is that
every bank has to do two-factor then no
one's gonna leave your bank because of
that versus for you guys they very well
might and you know it's possible that
your product isn't their most valued one
so they don't want to factor out there
is a very wide range I've seen from
industry reports anywhere between 30 and
like 65 percent so I'd say we're on the
nice always SMS for those but that said
I've gotten that from like white paper
reports that usually have very little
really to 65 was what I've seen upper
bad at least from what they're reporting
that said the honesty of that reporting
I cannot necessarily
the one the white papers I've seen are
usually from the two-factor vendors who
obviously have some incentive to you
like do some doctoring to those numbers
I wouldn't be surprised if it's if it is
lower that's just what I've seen kind of
publicly I've never seen a bank report
yeah yeah I'm trying to remember yeah I
don't remember that wanted they thank
you yeah yeah you kids are interesting
like I mentioned them as a resource here
but they may or may not be even a good
resource because there's some literature
that they're really hard to set up and
then people worry about losing them and
yeah so I think yeah that's I mean I
it's a tear point I think that em
truckers in general are more internet
savvy and do more security behaviors so
their uptake will be will be higher and
also they had like much stronger
incentives to care I think
yes yeah yeah yes so this is the I'm
going to pronounce his name wrong but
Traverse key and Kahneman a lot of their
experiments and basically what they felt
was going on wasn't that they were doing
math but that they were much better at
estimating their various resources or
cost so like if you asked a high
resource user to estimate how much they
would spend on vacation their estimate
would be much further off than someone
who has very little money to spend
that was their I know just general yeah
yes yes yes yes oh yes yeah yeah yeah
that one was actually at CCS about the
service analogs yeah yes so right we
basically wanted to see how well the
models align and that we generated and
so well we found is the log data is much
better for looking at detailed
constraints so basically if I'm looking
at software updating so here's an
example message that they might have
seen about it Dobby reader and then we
would ask them you know how quickly do
you think you would install the update
and we can match this to our log records
okay and so what we see is that we had a
bunch of these different messages that
were one-off variations from each other
in terms of things like what application
it was how costly was the update in like
whether or not you have to restart the
machine did it say that it was a
security was it a security only update
or I didn't mention that you get some
features and then finally how long was
the message and when you look at the the
survey data and the log data models
that's rated it doesn't really do a very
good job of matching so the log data on
these detailed constraints and the
reason we think that is is that when I'm
reading this in a survey the fact that I
might have to restart theoretically
isn't really that salient to me and same
with like I might get features I don't
want and so forth on the other hand we
wanted to look at things like how risky
do you think doing the update is like do
you think it's gonna make your machine
crash more etc and that's actually
pretty hard to measure in logs so we can
look at like number of system crashes
before and after updates of the same
type over some amount of years we can
look at application crashes but that
doesn't seem to to map perfectly to
people's perception of like how risky it
is to do this update and similarly with
looking at their like general tendency
to update I only have sort of so much
data from these computer logs I didn't
have mobile phones in this and so the
models we got based on asking these
general questions seemed better from the
survey data and we were able to ask kind
of more nuanced questions about
perception of risk or perception of like
what they usually do in the survey so it
seems to us if you're wanting to test
message variations you really should use
log data or some sort of observational
system and but if you're wanting to ask
about general contracts than surveys may
even be better or give you a lot more
resources or you may want to you know be
able to to pop up surveys occasionally
to your users whose logs you're tracking
this was semantic and so they have
tutored Demetrius who's a professor at
Maryland used to work at Symantec and
made this big wine systems at white yeah
these were all windows yes and all the
people we surveyed were also just
windows yeah yeah you mentioned that the
shopping spam was more sophisticated
yeah yeah yeah absolutely right so we
have some suggestions for like what do I
do about shopping Samba tomorrow won't
be shopping today will be something else
yeah this was part of why I had the
suggestion to them around like
click-through rates and also separating
out classifiers by topic because at the
time it was just sort of like all spam
is spam and it's pretty clear from these
results but that's not true and so I
think we need to do better like tracking
almost of like what are the rising
trends like I think about this a bit
like marketing right in that you know
marketing agencies are gonna track what
are the best ads right now and whether
the things about these ads that are
especially effective and they're gonna
try to like replicate that and spam we
don't necessarily think of it that way
but that's what the spammer is doing and
so I think looking at click-through rate
and also even like features of what like
what's the call to action in the spam
that's working really well is something
that would be helpful yeah
I exist via email too